Whether animated, on film, or on TV, Gotham's
resident murdering maniac The Joker is always
memorable.
For every actor who’s given his unnerving
cackle to the Joker, there are plenty of notable
actors who just narrowly missed the part.
Here are some actors who almost played the
Joker.
José Ferrer
Now you might not be familiar with José Ferrer's
acting résumé, but the Academy Award winner
was a big deal when producers were casting
the original 1966 Batman TV series.
According to producer William Dozier’s original
production notes, Ferrer was reportedly up
for the role of the Joker, but the actor had
scheduling issues.
"We also tried one other for The Joker, and
I'm glad we didn't get him, because I think
Cesar Romero is just magnificent."
Cesar Romero eventually edged Ferrer out...even
though Romero refused to shave his trademark
mustache.
Despite Ferrer missing the part, his son Miguel
went on to voice a slew of famous DC Comics
characters, including Martian Manhunter, Weather
Wizard, and Aquaman.
"Surface dwellers, they're about to cause
the death of millions, I have to stop them."
Frank Sinatra
Adam West's campy Batman attracted some huge
Hollywood stars as important villains, including
Eartha Kitt, Burgess Meredith, and Frank Gorshin.
According to Burt Ward’s memoir, Boy Wonder:
My Life in Tights, Frank Sinatra wanted in
on the Joker action, but arrived after Cesar
Romero had already signed on, upsetting the
hopeful Sinatra.
(Sinatra singing sad clown song, poor guy)
While a crooning Joker certainly would have
made the clown's elaborate cruelties even
weirder, Sinatra posthumously scored his Joker
connection in Rocksteady's Batman: Arkham
Knight game, where his rendition of "I've
Got You Under My Skin" plays a vital role
in a Joker-related scene.
Tim Curry
No stranger to playing monsters and creepy
clowns, Tim Curry missed out on the role of
the Joker in two separate productions.
Curry was among many familiar actors who were
on Tim Burton's shortlist for the iconic 1989
Batman, but the eternally-creepy Jack Nicholson
ultimately won the role.
Curry then went on to record multiple episodes
of Batman: The Animated Series as the Joker...before
being replaced by Mark Hamill.
Reportedly, Curry's Joker was a bit too terrifying
for the kiddie demographic, and it also strained
Curry’s voice.
He did, however, lend his laugh to a robot
clown later in the series.
Close enough.
"Ah ha ha ha!
Ah ha ha ha!
Ah ha ha ha!"
Robin Williams
One of the greatest Batman tragedies is the
fact that Robin Williams never had a chance
to play the Joker.
As a true comic nerd, Williams revealed in
a 2010 interview with Empire Magazine that
he was thrilled when he was offered the villainous
role in Burton’s Batman after Nicholson
first declined the part.
Until Nicholson changed his mind.
The two seemed to remain cordial, however.
"When I won my Academy Award he was there,
he won, this was his 3rd Academy Award.
We're standing backstage cause they're just
about to take you to the press conference,
and he goes, 'Ya know Rob-o now I have one
for every decade.'
You bastard!"
Williams had a second chance at the franchise
as the Riddler in Batman Forever, but again,
the role was yanked out from under him in
favor of Jim Carrey.
According to a 2006 IGN interview, Williams
also tried to get into Christopher Nolan's
trilogy, but was passed over for Heath Ledger.
No actor had ever wanted it so badly.
John Lithgow
Also on the shortlist to play Tim Burton's
Joker, John Lithgow reportedly declined the
role, stating that the character didn't seem
appropriate for his particular set of skills.
"Don't care whooo whooo whooo!"
Many years later, Lithgow would play an incredible,
viciously memorable serial killer on Dexter,
proving that the depths of his depiction of
evil would have been excellent against Michael
Keaton's Batman.
Instead, Lithgow wasted his time in 1989 on
a made-for-TV movie.
Willem Dafoe
When you kinda look like the Joker before
you even sit in the makeup chair, you're an
easy casting decision.
Willem Dafoe was another actor who was briefly
considered for the 1989 film role, simply
because he looked the part naturally.
He later landed the role of the Green Goblin
in 2002’s Spider-Man, another cackling supervillain
who is pretty much Marvel's answer to the
Joker anyhow.
"Heh heh heh heh"
Sam Rockwell
Peek through Sam Rockwell's acting history
and you'll see that he can do just about anything.
He's rarely failed a role, even as the nameless
punk ringleader in Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Rockwell was considered by Christopher Nolan
for The Dark Knight, but producers ultimately
went with Heath Ledger instead, leaving this
caliber of performance behind.
"Oh my holy crap, surveillance does, I hate
those."
Adrien Brody
Another Dark Knight contender, Adrien Brody
has publicly expressed an interest in playing
the Joker, according to MoviePilot.com.
Rumors arose regarding Brody making a Joker
cameo in Batman versus Superman: Dawn of Justice,
but Jared Leto ultimately took over in the
role in DC's Extended Universe.
Brody stated at Cannes in 2014 that no one
ever approaches him for comic book roles,
but there's truly no better role to fill with
completely offbeat casting.
Ryan Gosling
According to The Wrap, Suicide Squad's director
David Ayer was aiming for Ryan Gosling to
play the Clown Prince of Crime, but got Jared
Leto instead.
Gosling's pretty-boy Joker would have been
a bizarre contrast to the twisted Jokers of
years past, but it's hard to get the ever-changing
Joker totally wrong.
It's the Joker's paradox: the more wrong you
make him, the better he gets.
That laugh is on point, though.
"Ah ha ha ha ha haaaa!"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Joker you wish you could've seen...